este teatro infantil de left es ahora
una residencia para desplazados internos
y habla de estar ayudando
ambos originarios de mariupol no saben
nada de sus familias desde hace 4 días
no sabemos si tienen comida o agua o
electricidad o incluso si están vivos es
realmente una sensación terrible cuando
ves la foto de un cadáver y piensas
genial no es un conocido pero nos
alegramos cuando matan a soldados rusos
y así será hasta que se vayan
[Música]
estos amigos actores de profesión
acabaron en el teatro ofreciendo
consejos y vigilando a los impostores
hola
está registrada
registrada donde en el interior mujeres
y niños que huyeron de otras partes de
ucrania y no tiene ni idea de lo que les
depara el futuro
cómo podremos perdonarlos por esto no no
existe tal perdón por supuesto que no
nunca hoy en día muchos reconstruyen los
crímenes del régimen soviético como
crímenes de los rusos contra los
ucranianos o sea su creencia fiesta
historia principios los ucranianos
pueden encontrar una historia si repasan
su árbol genealógico de algún miembro
que fue ejecutado y lo que recuerdan
estos saben que no se puede esperar nada
bueno de los rusos ucranianos saben muy
bien que la mayoría de los rusos no han
asistido a las protestas contra la
guerra
no podemos perdonar a los rusos por su
silencio el silencio es complicidad en
la agresión todo esto en pleno domingo
del perdón del calendario cristiano
ortodoxo
pero según el padre andrew de esta
iglesia de los suburbios del lif no hay
necesidad de perdonar a putin
crisis postor años de cono
justo por 17 reto está en el libro de
deuteronomio maldito sea el que vio en
el territorio de su vecino podemos rezar
por el pueblo ruso como pueblo perdido
pero no por los que dirigen esta guerra
no dios no lo permitamos
a menos de dos semanas de la completa
invasión de rusia en ucrania ya es claro
que los lazos entre estos dos países
están rotos por generaciones de
generación